the United States has been played
beautifully like a fiddle because you
had a different kind of a leader we're
not gonna be played
things have changed very radically from
a few months ago but we're setting up
meetings now we're down to two countries
as to a site something very dramatic
could happen we're committed to
achieving permanent verifiable
irreversible dismantling of North
Koreans weapons of mass destruction
programs without delay it's certainly
something that I hope I can do for the
world well it was a big moment with the
two leaders North Korea's leader Kim
jong-un and South Korea's president
coming to the DMZ the area that we've
seen before between the two countries
stepping over into each other's
territory and talking laying the
groundwork for a possible peace and also
laying the groundwork for president
Trump's meeting with Kim jong-un
this follows obviously the CIA director
Mike Pompeo s visits to North Korea over
Easter weekend and a picture of him
shaking hands with the North Korean
leader what about this we'll start there
a lot to cover today with this news
conference at the White House let's
bring in our panel byron york political
correspondent chief political
correspondent for the Washington
Examiner Abie Stoddard is associate
editor at real clear politics and host
of No Labels radio on Sirius XM and
Jason Riley Wall Street Journal
columnist and senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute Jason your thoughts
on what we heard from the president
today well I didn't see a lot of warmth
there between us so a little bit of a
frost it's a little different than the
French France visit and a little
different but interestingly I think both
France and Germany want something
similar here they don't though they're
wary of the u.s. pulling out of the Iran
deal they don't like Trump's talks of
tariffs on imports of aluminum and steel
so they're trying to get him to scale
that back or at least give them
exemptions on that front so you see some
similarities there but what I saw some
very strong language out of Donald Trump
particularly with regard to Iran and
then
and how he is going to make sure that we
provide deterrence to them acquiring
nuclear weapons and France seemed a
little more open to that McCrone seem a
little more open to that particularly
when it comes to things like sunset
provisions that were concerned about or
inspections where we can go
he seems open to to at least making
another deal that addresses some of
these concerns I'm not sure if Merkel is
quite there yet on Korea the president
tweeting a furious year missile launches
nuclear testing historic meeting between
the North and South now for taking place
good things are happening only time will
tell
Korean War to end the United States and
all of its great people should be very
proud of what's now taking place in
Korea please do not forget the great
help that my good friend President Xi of
China has given to the United States
particularly at the border of North
Korea without him it would have been a
much longer tougher process I mean
they're laying the groundwork here for
something really significant I mean it
look this is all good news and the
president deserves all the credit for
whatever he has done to push the Chinese
to the table in terms of enforcement and
of course to get the sanctions past this
very tough sanctions through the UN that
that are obviously inflicting pain on
the regime in North Korea the the
meeting last night you know it was not
unprecedented that these two sides would
talk but the actual physical meeting and
and everything bodes very well they
didn't get specific they didn't promise
to end the Korean War we don't know
exactly what they're they didn't commit
to any pledges but it's very very
hopeful and I thought it was very
interesting that the president took
pains to credit President Xi for for
really being for enforcing the sanctions
and for being a credible partner I think
the South Koreans and the North Koreans
obviously the North Koreans would like
to separate us from the Chinese and the
South Koreans the Japanese are very
skeptical there's an entirely possible
scenario in which he has developed his
nuclear weapons program so far that he
can get to the table and say guess what
it's been great meeting with you I might
talk to you about a freeze in exchange
for some things but I'm not going to
dismantle
I haven't this president says Byron he's
gonna walk away right doesn't do that
yes but I mean this atmosphere is just
an incredible change from the threats we
were seeing being exchanged not very
long ago and you have to have all of the
caveats chem can't be trusted there have
been these north-south agreements before
that never went anywhere and the US has
to make sure it always rewards only
actions never rewards promises but on
the other hand this is a big deal and
there's one person who is more
responsible than anybody else for it and
that is President trumpets it's the
sanctions and also this attitude if I
just might be crazy enough to do
something that seems to have made
something happen but but
Byron's right we've had north/south
agreements before we've had these
summits before we've had these joint
declarations before the fact of the
matter is the the North Korean
Constitution calls for the end of South
Korea it has since 1953 it still does
we have no specifics on that we have
nothing on human rights here the most
reassuring thing I've heard though is
what you just referred to President
Trump says he is willing to walk away I
I hope that the president doesn't feel
if he gets into this room or into these
meetings I've got to cut a deal or I'll
look like a failure no unless you're
gonna get something substantive I hope
he is just willing to walk away because
the North Koreans cannot be trusted
here's the president today on the House
Intelligence Russia investigation I was
very honored by the report it was
totally conclusive there was no
collusion with Russia you can believe
this one there was she probably can't
believe it
the committee did not use its subpoena
power for bank records for phone records
it's basically a kindergarten report it
was a light once-over
so obviously Democrats Byron not not
happy with the report of the findings
the pattern of Russian attacks
cyberattacks meet both the US and Europe
none of the interviewed witnesses
provide evidence of collusion
coordination or conspiracy between the
Trump campaign and Russia opposition
research on Trump makes its way from
Russian sources to the Clinton campaign
problematic contacts between senior
intelligence community officials and the
media I do want to play this one of the
other things that comes out of it is
about Mike Flynn and I asked Jim Comey
about that did you tell lawmakers that
FBI agents didn't believe former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
was lying intentionally to investigators
no you didn't I saw that in the media I
don't know what maybe someone
misunderstood something I said I didn't
believe that and didn't say that if he
does not remember telling Congress that
his agents told him they didn't think
Flynn was lying then he needs to get his
lawyers to go back and look at the
transcript we did not miss here maybe he
misspoke but that's in the transcript so
in this report general Flynn pleaded
guilty to making a false statement to
the Federal Bureau of Investigation
regarding his December 2016
conversations with the Russian
ambassador kiss the act even though the
Federal Bureau of Investigation agents
did not detect any deception during
Flynn's interview barn
well James Comey has denied this a
couple of times so far it has been
reported I reported that not too long
ago that in this meeting in March of
2017 the Congress had been demanding
briefings from call me and he indeed
told them that the key word here is
transcript that's what trey Gowdy was
talking about his meeting with the House
Intelligence Committee was transcribed
and you have to think that it's probably
in this report that just got released
today if anybody's looked at this report
there's big black sections of things
that are redacted and the House
Committee said not all of this stuff is
classified and we
going to release a less redacted version
of it in the near future
quickly a be even Gowdy has said listen
Muller is the Big Kahuna here because
there were witnesses they wanted to talk
to they didn't talk to in this house
until yeah there are just things that
Muller can do that these committees on
Capitol couldn't do and the process
broke down it was a tainted partisan
process this report is not credible I
don't give any credence to the
democratic report we should we all be
waiting for what Bob Muller comes up
with